in the gi joe comics
snake eyes is one of those characters
that's had kind of a mysterious past
it was famously known as the silent
ninja
this is morning night larry hammer
really blossomed the character
within an issue called the silent
interlude which had
no words just pictures when i did the
comic
i made it character-centric i came up
with the backstory of storm shadow takes
snake eyes
into the clan larry hama created the
modern day version of what we know gi
joe to be
we try to find a balance between what is
pre-existing
gi joe law but also finding a way of
updating it
giving people more
that opened up a world of opportunity
let's do the origin story before he's
lost his voice
let's go shooting in japan
was super important for driving a story
when you go to japan there's some energy
that you pick up from actually being
there
i'm super excited for people to see what
we're building
this is literally a stepping stone into
the gi joe universe
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my snake eyes movie trailer video for
the gi joe origin story as you can tell
this is meant to be a new origin
for a new version of a gi joe cinematic
universe
and knowing is half the battle
everyone post all the memes so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i'm sure
at some point in everyone's history here
no matter how old you are you've
encountered a version of gi joe
whether you just watched the films from
the early 2000s the cartoon series or if
you watched the og classic cartoon
series or if you're even older and you
actually had some of the larger toys
that predated the gi joe real american
hero line
when most people think of the classic gi
joe stories you're actually thinking
about the 1980s gi joe real american
hero story that was actually created by
larry hamma
for marvel comics as part of the brand
new rebooted toy line that hasbro was
introducing
we're talking the classic era of
saturday morning cartoons here
that original larry hamma gi joe marvel
comic book was actually the first one
that was ever advertised on television
as part of that animated series
and if you don't remember they actually
did an animated movie
based on that series a long time ago it
was in 1987 it's kind of hard to track
down but i think it's on amazon at the
moment
but the whole idea is that they're
trying to reinvigorate the gi joe ip so
this is meant to be a new origin for new
versions of all these characters and
they just wanted to start with a single
character instead of trying to do a
straight up
full-blown gi joe movie but as you can
see there are a bunch of classic gi joe
characters in this like you even have
the baroness so you have some cobra
characters you have scarlet that's your
gi joe character right there
the reason why scarlett is in this is
because she has history with snake eyes
that predates g.i joe
there have been a lot of different
versions of their backstories in the
comics but this is mostly going to be
referencing the classic larry hamma
version because as you can see from the
featurette they basically brought him
onto the movie to help them sort of
move the timeline into present day so
all these origin stories that they're
doing with the snake eyes origin story
is based on the classic version just
updated with modern references
so if it's been a hot minute since
you've seen that classic animated series
or if you never read the original comics
or anything like that
the whole idea is that snake ice and
storm shadow were actually squad mates
during the vietnam war in the 1970s
because it was meant to be an origin
story for the 1980s version of the
character
obviously he's not meant to be mute
during this they'll show you how he
became mute eventually i don't know if
they'll do in this film or one of the
sequels
but the whole idea is that when zartan
was killing his master he shot snake
eyes in the throat
to keep him from shouting out to warn
him so that he could save himself
so he's mute because he got shot in the
throat in the funny story about them
actually creating his iconic black suit
that he wears it
looks so badass is they actually said it
was based on this really weird situation
that they ran into with manufacturing
the toy line
i believe the story was they were trying
to sell an extra action figure
as part of the new 1980s rebooted toy
line
but in order for it to be profitable
enough for them to justify
doing it they actually had to find a way
to make the action figure without
spending money on a bunch of
die for the actual plastic parts of the
figure so they said
what if we don't color the action figure
at all we'll just release a black action
figure uncolored essentially
so that's like a version of the real
story of how he wound up getting that
black costume
but the reason why they wanted to do
snake eyes as this new origin story is
because he's probably one of the most
badass characters of all time in the gi
joe line
so even though they don't totally
clarify where he was before he joined
the arasha kage here
it sounds like maybe they'll use the war
in iraq or the war in afghanistan or one
of the more recent conflicts around the
globe then he meets tommy
storm shadow storm shadow's real name is
tommy arashikage
and tommy offers him a place in the
arashikage so he brings him to japan
here
so when telling the origin of snake eyes
they're also giving an origin story for
storm shadow as well so they can kind of
explain their relationship in present
day and why they're such bitter rivals
but also do a version of an origin story
for some of the gi joe characters like
scarlet
and some of the cobra characters like
the baroness the actual synopsis for the
movie just reads an ancient japanese
clan
called the arashikage welcomes tenacious
loner snake eyes after he saves the life
of the heir apparent
that's storm shadow that they're talking
about upon arrival in japan the
arashikage teach him the ways of the
ninja warrior
while also providing him something he's
been longing for a home
however when secrets from snake eyes
past are revealed his honor and
allegiance get tested
even if that means losing the trust of
those closest to him but henry golding
said this opening fight scene from the
trailer is just supposed to be them
showing you some classic snake eyes
moves
like they wanted to do the classic uzi
shot from the original series
but you have a couple arashikage
characters like storm shadow and akiko
is the other character here you see her
in the later trailer she's one of the
fellow ninjas training is part of the
rashikage
under blind master she might be a
version of the jinx character that was
played by elodie young
during the gi joe retaliation movie most
of you probably remember her more
recently though as
elektra from marvel's daredevil on
netflix and the defenders
she actually kind of feels like an
electra type character so even though
this version of the character is named
akiko i think it's meant to be the same
concept
peter mensah is playing their blind
master most of you probably know a
version of that original origin story
this sort of sets up the idea of their
rivalry during the animated series and
some of the later stories
they flash back to explain what their
big falling out was
but this movie is meant to give you like
the full version of that because in the
classic comics like they feature the
classic comic with larry hama where he
told his origin story
they gave you sort of a short version of
that this is just meant to be the full
version
originally the story is is the storm
shadows character who's known as
soft master within the arashikage wanted
their sensei blind mastered to teach
them the seventh
step to the sun technique which would
allow you to kill your opponent within
seven blows
in that version of the story blind
master is supposed to be his uncle so
they're actually family members like
storm shadow's
real last name is rashikage after the
name of the clan
they call him the heir apparent during
this movie so like he's supposed to
eventually take over the clan someday
but their sensei blind master refuses to
teach him the move and instead seems
like he favors
snake eyes so they try to set it up as
this big jealousy thing with storm
shadow being jealous of snake eyes
and killing their sensei blind master in
revenge
snake eyes retaliates to try and get
revenge for the death of their master
blames storm shadow thinking that he
killed their master this whole time so
that also extends into present day he
holds this grudge against him for the
rest of their life
but then later it's found out that
zartan is part of cobra was actually
manipulating things from behind the
scenes and he's the person that really
killed their master
so it's just a way to show you that even
though they have this intense rivalry
that extends into present day when
they're part of gi joe and part of cobra
they still have this deep connection to
each other so they're going to try and
develop that during this movie
it's sort of like captain america in the
winter soldier after they meet again
after bucky has become winter soldier
and killed a ton of people
like he's my friend even though he's
done a lot of
really really bad stuff you see a couple
different fights with storm shadow on
his own fighting the other yakuza
interestingly enough they did not reveal
who the main villain of the movie is
going
to be if it's going to be somehow
related to the rise of cobra in the
background if they're trying to develop
a new version of an origin story for
that organization of those characters
i know there'll be a lot of comparisons
with shangshin the legend of the 10
rings
another big martial arts based movie
that's coming out just a little while
after this shengqin the legend of the
ten rings is coming out in september
this is coming out at the end of july
right after the black widow movie
the big difference is that snake eyes is
drawing more on japanese history with
ninjutsu
in shengshen the legend of the ten rings
is drawing more on chinese history and
mythology through kung fu
the funny thing about shanghi is that
you'll recognize they use the exact same
music track
in this trailer that they used in the
shang chi trailer they released a little
while ago
the whole idea with shengshin the legend
of the ten rings is the character
shengxi
actually comes from a comic book that
was titled master of kung fu
but he was sort of marvel's version of
bruce lee so interesting coincidence
that larry hamma who was actually an
editor at marvel
when he started that classic gi joe
comic book so it all goes back to marvel
in the end
even though the history of gi joe
pre-dates marvel comics by a lot like gi
joe goes back to the 1940s there was the
original line of action figures the
really big ones maybe some of you if
you're a little bit older you had one of
those like even my grandpa who fought
during the korean war in the 1950s grew
up with a version of gi joe
so far the movie seems pretty decent i
think they made the right call in trying
to sort of reboot the gi joe universe
and start with the cooler characters and
just focus
on individual characters instead of
trying to do everything all at once
i think the idea is they have direct
snake eye sequels and then eventually
you'll start seeing some of the other gi
joe characters the other cobra
characters
then within like three or four years
maybe way down the road you'll actually
see
a brand new full-blown gi joe movie like
they're going to do at the marvel
avengers route you do the individual
character movies then you build up to
the team up movie
their version of avengers would be a gi
joe film so even more marvel references
like
based on a story that was done for
marvel comics now
doing the movies in the marvel movie way
and even way back when they were getting
ready to cast
channy tatum as a version of duke chris
evans was supposedly up for a role
as that character before they went on
channing tatum and if you don't remember
ray park darth maul himself
played that version of snake eyes in
those 2000s movies
but everyone post all your reactions in
the comments below let me know what else
do you want them to do with the gi joe
ip
just because this is the brand new
beginning of a new
cinematic universe the only big cameos
that i'm expecting during the movie
would probably be like larry hamma
himself in the background of one of the
shots
he's sort of like the stan lee of the gi
joe universe
we also have marvel loki episodes that
are going to start releasing in a couple
weeks i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss
any of that
while you wait for everything click here
for that brand new loki trailer and
easter eggs and click here for my brand
new eternals teaser trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight